có thích báo mô đồng giữ sổ và gặng quế nhiều khu bực của Mỹ làm tây lệ rào thông hàng thông.
Gây thương vòng và có thể gián thư thịt thải kinh tế lên tới một trong người làm tỷ đủ là Mỹ.
Rửa liệu từ fly over cho thấy trong người hàng mấy rào thông một khoảng 5.2,5% này bị huy.
Và hơn 60% chuyên bài bị hoản sau khi gần môi một lì chuyển Mỹ huy một ngày trước đó,
hàng phần tin, siêu, gần người chính phần trong tổng số chuyên bài thương lịch trình đã không thể cất cánh.
Cô hàng thông lề báo Mỹ cạnh báo thư dài mưa băng và tập nghìn cánh.
Có thể bộ như sân bay lớn phép dụi biệt pháp dụng và đập mặt đất.
A Merry Christmas, chuẩn thường nặng nề nhất với hàng nghìn chuyên bài bị gián đoạn tại cơ trung tâm lớn,
nhiều Dalas, Port Worth và khu bực đồng bắt.
Ngoài thị thải trong ngày hân không cần báo cộng chút lượng tích dài từ Nho Mỹ cô tới Nho Inland.
Hìa niên nhất mới tám người thịt mạng và kéo theo đường dựa dựa dạm sự kiến kiếm dạm dạm trung bài tồn.
Thì hợp ở KWIDER Tâm Thị thải và tổn thích tình tây dọ báo của thịt dọ động tương 1 trong ngày 6, đến 1 trong 1 làm tỷ đủ là Mỹ.
Nếu cân báo mùa đông này, trở thành 1 trung miếng đo thời tiết thực đoàn, gây tổn thật lớn nhất tại Mỹ trong những năm cành đây.